[Musik]
hallo lieber kollege blume sie sehen
dann wie eine zwischenfrage stellen
kurz bevor es losgeht ist jetzt schon
sommer bevor wir so waren doch auch bei
der bundeswehr wurde empfohlen und
sinnvollen das war eine liga in bologna
aber die bundeswehr das interessiert die
meisten zu sehen dazu wir wissen gar
nicht wovon wir reden wenn wir das sagen
wieso sie meinen meine lockeren ja
lockeren aussteller die ärmel hoch ist
und warum weil die lockerungen immer
weiter gehen an das kann gar nicht
locker genug sei aber ich habe mich
jetzt auch richtig locker gemacht dann
sitzen sie nackig hier wenn die türken
kaufland werden tatsächlich richtig
durch gelockerte bisschen beiseite
corona kommt die zweite welle nicht
fragezeichen ich erinnere mich und sie
erinnern sich vielleicht auch alle daran
dass vor zwei drei wochen sehr vehement
gewarnt wurde von eigentlich sehr vielen
leuten die wirklich was von
epidemiologie versteht aber auch
gefallen ganz ganz vielen die erste ich
möchte mal sagen spätgeborenen
epidemiologen waren die gesagt haben und
oft ist er jetzt lockert nach ihr werdet
das so bereuen
die zahlen der infektion werden
explodieren
keiner hält sich mehr an irgendwas seht
ihr die wahnsinnigen wie sie rum laufen
ohne maske und sich die hand geben und
so praktisch es war kurz vor armageddon
möchte ich fast sagen apokalypse
demnächst stand kurz bevor
es ist jetzt eine weile her die in
aktuellen zahlen geben das alles
überhaupt nicht her
was ist da passiert herr blume was ist
da passiert da haben sich hat sich das
traditionsblatt nein da hat sich also
kann man bestimmt auch noch mal kann man
geht ja nicht mehr ohne so eine sendung
zur krone schöne frankfurter die
präventions- paradox dass in der fremde
freuen dass wir eine debatte zwischen
der einen virologen epidemiologen formt
und der anderen sagt man kann locker
nehmen kann nicht so kann man kein
bisschen den wandel dollar hat sich
politik hat entschieden in diesem fall
waren es die ministerpräsidenten die
glaube ich
das uhr ein bisschen mehr auf das china
hatten vor zwei wochen als wir merkten
die stimmung kippt er hängt an sich zu
bewegen vielleicht sogar zu kippen in
der bevölkerung also lieber mal ein
bisschen lockern damit die leute das
gefühl kriegen da gibt es auch irgendwo
geht es weiter zurück möglicherweise in
ein normales leben und es war halt
riskant aber sie haben es gemacht und es
ist bislang gut gegangen was ja nicht
heißt also nun es gab eine fraktion
übrigens von wissenschaftern gesagt und
das wäre gut gehen es gab jetzt nicht
die front die politik gegen die
wissenschaft das war ja nicht so also
lediglich das war nicht so sondern es
war halt einige haben gewarnt und sich
vielleicht damit auf die sichere seite
gebracht markus söder war auch bei denen
die wanten dann bloß nicht so schnell
und dann gab es eine andere fraktion die
sich eher durchgesetzt hat und in der
fläche der 16 bundesländer ist es ja
auch unterschiedlich grenzer machen
spielt sich da nicht so runter sie sie
waren einmal bei der zeitung mit den
großen buchstaben beziehen sie ziehen
sozusagen alles was spannend und
kontrovers und ehrlich gesagt auch
vielleicht ganz leer ich jetzt gerade
aus dem thema raus indem sie es so
verbessern nein nein ganz kurz die
kollegin die wissenschaftsjournalistin
die im moment ganz überall zitiert wird
die die einen blog hat ein podcast macht
hatte 1 1
im internet dann bei twitter geschrieben
in diesen dieser april wird in die
geschichte eingehen
die virologen wären alle werden sagen
warum hat man nicht auf sie gehört und
sonst bei scream bei twitter durch die
decke 10.000 bis 15.000 likes alle leute
ja was für ein was für einen weg der
verderbnis wird hier beschritten und so
und jetzt haben wir in berlin da hatte
ich gerade gucken 29 neue fälle
und das sind 29 zu viel keine frage weil
das ist eine grausame krankheit und so
ist es allerdings weit davon weg dass
diese starke jetzt sozusagen untergeht
und ganz gut und wir reden hier von
berlin
aber ihr leben einander ich bin noch
nicht durch jährliche das müssen sie
sich anhören und ich finde die leute
sollten dass ich auch klammern wir reden
von berlin wo in wahrheit wenn sie
draußen sind sie jetzt fast nichts mehr
merken ich finde die leute verhalten
sich nämlich hier sehr rational und sehr
angemessen sie tragen masken so wie ich
das auch machen übrigens im supermarkt
sie tragen masken im öffentlichen
personennahverkehr und im wesentlichen
war es das dann auch schon so zu sagen
ja und was ich eben noch immer
katastrophal finden und es wäre dann
sozusagen mein liebster nicht in die
restaurants die hast du dich teil sogar
zum beispiel restaurant sitzt daneben
auch das fängt ja langsam wieder an ich
glaube daran müssen sich die leute erst
wieder gewöhnen so lisa sie kommen
langsam zu hören ist auf jeden fall
nicht so dass die restaurants aber aus
betont inzwischen knallvoll wären was
man ja unterstellen könnte wenn du mal
die hälfte der tische da ist aber nicht
der fall aber sie haben schon worauf ich
hinaus ich will doch darauf hinaus dass
wenn die leute die uns armageddon
angedroht haben wenn wir jetzt zu früh
locker sich in diesem doch sehr
wesentlichen punkt ganz offensichtlich
geirrt haben darf man das jetzt schon
sagen dass sie sich da gehört haben wie
groß ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie
sich auch vorher gehört haben ein
grosses fragezeichen was ich nicht okay
die antwort ist nicht das können weder
sie noch nicht beziffern
aber es gibt einige indizien die dem
soll man so die zumindest zurechtrücken
was das für ein irrtum gewesen wäre und
ob es statthaft war trotzdem anders zu
handeln nämlich ein jetzt nicht ganz
schaffen glaubt dann war es ja nicht
aber doch erhebliche einschränkungen zu
verfügen vor sechs acht wochen
wohlgemerkt
der erste punkt ist damals war die
biologie die epidemiologie einer meinung
jetzt muss man hier voll auf die bremse
lassen da gab es das nicht zwei lager
die einen sagten
kannst du machen ja dann sagten musst du
nicht machen sondern gab es wirklich 99
und ein halbes prozent sowie rollo
gesagt sollte man besser machen und dann
gab es ein paar einzelne und die will
ich jetzt gar nicht als irrer spinner
oder ich weiß nicht was disqualifizieren
aber wirklich sehr sehr wenigen sachen
quatsch das ist christ superstar muss
alles nicht sein so und der punkt ist
doch was würde beweisen
darauf waren sie in wahrheit hinaus sie
wollen ja mit der abwesenheit einer
zweiten welle beiden lockerten zuständen
beweisen dass die fordern vorne
befassten einschränkungen nicht nötig
gewesen wären weil auch jetzt bei
gelockert im zustand keine welle
entsteht also sah in ihrer these ist
doch man hätte weniger einschränken
müssen vielleicht gar nicht und das wäre
gar keine erste welle entstanden wir
haben jetzt eine einschränkung weiter
einschränkt und mir kommt es dafür aber
abstand jetzt seien es ist man sich doch
ehrlich kommt sie wollen auch jetzt hier
nicht rum kübeln sondern sie wollen in
frage stellen ob das am anfang richtig
was die bundesregierung hat sich auch
dass das eine und das und was mich aber
ärgert wenn das illegal wollen sich
jetzt über in zwei minuten oder lieber
ganz aus eigentlich sind auch was dazu
sagen
mich ärgert die selbstgewissheit dieser
leute und zwar und ich das ist jetzt
nicht rechthaberei das ist nicht nach
hinten treten darum geht es mir ja es
geht mir darum mechanismen von
öffentlicher debatte sozusagen zu prüfen
wie funktional will die eigentlich sind
und wenn sie in einer solchen situation
hatten wir vor drei vier wochen und eben
auch schon vor sechs und acht wochen es
zu tun mit einer welle aus
selbstsicherheit die wussten ganz genau
das muss jetzt so gemacht werden in
wahrheit wussten die das aber gar nicht
und das stört mich da war nämlich nicht
der zweifel dass wichtig wir hatten hier
das mit dem zweifel und wir haben eine
sendung gemacht da ging es darum da
waren wir ganz dicht daran den zweifel
irgendwie so das zu diskreditieren weil
er jetzt den wahnsinnigen demonstrieren
und so der zweifel ist aber zentral und
wir haben in den letzten wochen bei dem
coroner thema den zweifel fast
vollständig ausgeschaltet und wir haben
eine öffentliche debatten klima gehabt
wo die leute und wir wissen was richtig
ist und jetzt kann ich nur sagen freunde
sorry wenn er gewusst hätte was richtig
ist dann hätten wir jetzt schon wieder
gerade in einer stadt wie berlin das ist
eine undisziplinierte stadt deshalb mag
ich sie auch
so gerne ich bin selber auch ein
bisschen und diszipliniert übrigens
sowie christian lindner
der umarmt seinen kumpel dann auch mal
klammer auf da geht es eher um den usa
kusel von bildern ich finde es eher das
problem als turnaround aber so ich finde
sagen denn das selbst in berlin jetzt
die zahlen nicht durch die decke gehen
man dann möchtest du mal herrn
lauterbach sondern das mal klar
lauterbach bitte ag herr lauterbach
bitte kommen sie ans ohr
der täter dann hauptsächlich feld machte
das ja auch nachher noch einmal das
macht doch nur spaß was sie sagen dann
macht das nur sinn wenn sie mit der mit
dem jetzigen in ihrem sinne irrtum muss
man sagen nach einer fraktion der
virologen argumentieren können wer sich
einmal irrt da kann sich auch ein
zweites mal geirrt haben spielt so exakt
und jetzt und das ist ja mein punkt und
darum ist quasi ihr argument für leicht
logisch nachvollziehbar aber politisch
nicht implementierbar
denn versetzen wir das mal zurück da hat
also die damals gesammelte frontex rollo
gesagt das sehen wir jetzt mal so und so
und besser eine vollbremsung oder eine
scharfe bremsung sofort wollen so war es
ja nicht eine scharfe bremsung als der
weniger scharfe das war so wenig so
zusammenfassen darf der diese ansicht
der wissenschaft also der versammelten
wissenschaftler mit unterschiedlichen
nuancen der ctc so und jetzt hätte die
politik hingehen sollen
und sagen sollen wir wissen es besser
als 99 und ein halbes prozent der wiro
dokument jetzt muss ich zu erheben
dürfen wir wissen es besser als diese
gruppe sehr heterogener virologen die
uns das nur raten wir lassen das jetzt
mal und schauen was passiert
das haben einzelne länder gemacht und
das ist mein zweiter punkt also in
teilen ist es falsifiziert dieses lasst
uns mal weniger bremsen oder lassen es
später bremsen ist falsifiziert durch
die ereignisse finde ich in
großbritannien den usa auf eine art auch
in spanien und lassen was anderes geht
es darum dass diese virologen und die
journalisten die ihnen das wort geredet
haben mit einem gestus der
selbstsicherheit und der gewissheit
aufgetreten sind hatten sie schon damals
nicht haben konnten und das konnte man
wissen dass die das nicht wissen können
sie taten aber so und jetzt sozusagen
entschuldigung ich weiß es klingt jetzt
ein bisschen blöd aber man muss ja auch
mal lernen aus dingen meine wir können
natürlich immer so weiter machen nur
nach vorne gucken sagen es ist ganz egal
wie das gelaufen ist konnte nur so
laufen wie es gelaufen ist es
interessiert mich überhaupt nicht
immer noch vorne ist auch eine art und
weise halte ich für ein bisschen
beschränkt ich würde sagen lasst doch
mal zurückkommen und gucken wie ist es
eigentlich verlaufen was lernen wir
daraus und ich würde zum beispiel daraus
lernen learnings für die zukunft ja soll
doch alles anders werden soll nachhaltig
dass ihre pläne für die zukunft tipp für
die journalisten für die kollegen die
alles ganz genau wissen vorher mal
nachdenken ob das wirklich alles so
stimmen muss denn in diesem fall aber
das ist sowohl fall sprechen die fakten
aber was es gibt nichts daraus zu leise
es gibt es nichts zu lernen natürlich
gibt es da auch etwas zum nahen osten
ist der banale ja der banale satz
wissenschaftler sogar die mehrheit der
wissenschaftler könnten sich theoretisch
irgendwo unterschreibe ich sofort
so ein pech gehabt haben wir reichlich
pech gehabt
sie müssen ja die frage stellen hätte
man würde man beim nächsten mal ist
anders machen wenn man wieder in der
lage wäre unbekannter virus in
bestimmten ländern haben wir es etwas
später gesehen und dann hohen preis
dafür gezahlt
180 von 183 ländern machen es so in
diesem kranz von daten machen wir es
beim nächsten mal dann also anders und
deutschland sagt egal es ist die zweite
welle damals nicht gekommen die erste
haben wir verhindert die zweite ist
nicht gekommen
jetzt lassen wir das problem dass man
anders herum und lassen das ding laufen
wenn sie in der ungewissheit sind muss
die politik finde ich hat die politik
erreicht hat die politik pflicht zur
vorsicht und pflicht zur vorbeuge ich
werde ihnen versagt ich will einfach nur
mal normale leute aber das argument im
nachhinein ist es nicht weil das
argument der ifi ziert sich immer selbst
kann man sagen hier sicher desto besser
better safe than sorry und gelassen
jetzt alle einsperren weil wir nicht
wissen ob sie mal nein so können sie
keine entschuldigung das geht so nicht
und wir haben einen konkreten fall jetzt
gerade geht es nämlich um die frage was
ist eigentlich mit den schülern was
nämlich mit den kindern ironischerweise
wird jetzt ja so getan als sei
deutschland bereits total locker wie
dann alles wieder auf dem weg zur
normalität da kann ich nur sagen wer das
sagt hat keine kinder
während es stimmt halt nicht denn die
kindergärten sind geschlossen und also
ich kenne keine schule die normal
funktioniert meine drei kinder gehen ich
glaube einmal im monat in die schule
oder so also ehrlich gesagt da ist also
weit weit weg wandern normalität und
jetzt habe ich gerade gelesen dass vier
medizinische fachgesellschaften ja das
ist jetzt nicht irgend so ein abgewendet
typ von einer ecke sondern sondern das
sind praktisch die leute die sich
auskennen sagen
macht die schulen wieder auf weil den
kindern etwas antun und was im spiegel
online entschuldigung ich muss jetzt mal
direkt sein spiegel online bringt diese
meldung und das ist der preis den ich
meine so die forderung ist spektakulär
und sie richtet sich gegen die klare
empfehlung von christian drosten
und die leute das so können praktisch
die leute das nur verkaufen sagt kann es
sein dass auch christian drosten sich in
natürlichen und diese und die anderen
leute sagen freunde es ist höchste zeit
schluss zu mehrheiten im kreis hat sich
hat sich geirrt er kann sehr hat sich
auf der strecke ich auch 15 jahren
übrigens hätten diese journalisten ja
immer noch nicht diese journalisten so
eine einzelne bestimmte vielleicht aber
ja nicht der journalismus und noch
einmal
ich glaube auch man müsste jetzt
schneller lockern als langsam aber damit
und das ist der entscheidende punkt und
darum geht er in wahrheit die debatte
diskreditieren oder falsifizieren sie
doch die ursprünglichen entscheidung
darüber können sie noch hauptsächlich
was sagen über die zeit jetzt und
sachsen zum beispiel macht die schulen
also da entsteht dann sieht also nach
her können wir sogar ein fallbeispiel
machen was passiert in sachsen und
anderen ländern wo sie später in die
schule dürfen
lasst die kinder wieder zur schule gehen
sie wollen ihre kinder los werden ja
toll
[Musik]